5 25 on your Monday morning got an
update on the project that yeah it's
going to be even bigger than that big
squeeze on the 95 515
well this logo should look familiar to
the Nevada Department of
transportation's downtown Access Project
otherwise known as n.dap gonna bring
huge construction changes to the 95 95
515 from Rancho west of the spaghetti
Bowl all the way over to Pecos now that
big squeeze project that was all about
making the old freeway safer to drive on
n.dap's going to see a complete rebuild
of the area multiple options on the
table from putting the freeway on the
ground to keeping it above ground but
shifting it either north or south of the
current layout the big updates that ndot
has opened an office where you can learn
more about the project in the newly
renovated city of Las Vegas East Las
Vegas Community Center at Eastern and
Stewart just south of the freeway
but don't expect to see cranes or
construction equipment anytime soon the
current timeline has that happening
closer to the end of the decade got a
link to the N dot dap webpage in the
online version of this story visit
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully and
please put on that phone you can join
the driving you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com